Javier Bardem opens up about wife  Penelope Cruz's new role as Donatella  Versace in American crime story it's  pretty fantastic ET spoke with the 48  year old actor at the pirates of the  caribbean dead men tell no tales  premiere on wednesday  you went blonde for spectre and we're  loving the photos of penelope with the  blonde wig is Donatella Versace what was  your reaction when you first saw her as  a blonde like that well I seen the  preparation and uh but when the whole  thing comes together it was spectacular  not only that the look is great but that  what she's doing with the character it's  pretty fantastic and also it's in the  hands of one of the bests Ryan Murphy  which I have the pleasure and the joy to  work with in it for a love so I can't  wait to see it I think it should be  something special blondes have more fun  you would know I don't know  [Music]